y
[Música]
finalizó la cumbre extraordinaria de
líderes de la unión europea con el pacto
sobre el embargo de más de dos tercios
del petróleo ruso por el acuerdo de
reabastecer militarmente a ucrania con
urgencia ampliamos las de bruselas
las tropas rusas continúan su ofensiva
tras lograr el control de al menos un
tercio de la ciudad de severodonezk los
ataques también continúan sobre el isi
chance que es liviana y liman la onu
cifró en más de 4000 los civiles muertos
desde el inicio de la guerra
en el día mundial sin tabaco en la
organización mundial de la salud recordó
que este producto causa unos 8 millones
de muertes anuales que además ha
alertado que el tabaco genera toneladas
de desechos y contribuye al
calentamiento global pues sus emisiones
son equivalentes a la quinta parte de
las de la aviación civil
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos esta emisión de
noticias en la capital belga donde los
líderes de la unión europea exigieron a
rusia que levante el bloqueo de los
puertos ucranianos para permitir las
exportaciones de alimentos al tiempo
acordaron coordinar un reabastecimiento
de armas para ucrania esto luego de que
el lunes pactar un embargo de dos
tercios de las importaciones de petróleo
ruso
of russia no sólo está bloqueando la
exportación de trigo ucraniano está
bombardeando deliberadamente los
almacenes donde almacena el trigo por
supuesto saben que también están minando
los campos donde ucrania podría tener la
próxima cosecha de maíz
y quiero ser muy claro no tenemos
sanciones sobre alimentos y productos
agrícolas no hay sanciones sobre eso
food and agriculture tracks náuseas por
los que están plomo para decirlo con
toda sencillez las decisiones que hemos
tomado en el sexto paquete de sanciones
y todo lo que vamos a tomar su contra
para muchos países cortar las
infraestructuras existentes rehacer
completamente las refinerías y las
estructuras y esta es una inversión que
será acompañada precisamente por este
mecanismo repower de la unión europea
otro tipo y justamente en este contexto
la estatal rusa gazprom cortó hoy el
suministro de gas a países bajos y se
espera que mañana se suspenda el
servicio a dinamarca pero volviendo a la
cumbre el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski agradeció en las sanciones
contra rusia pero aseguró que se
demoraron demasiado
conversamos con esther herrera
corresponsal de france 24 quien nos
explicó qué significan para rusia y para
los países europeos las sanciones
alcanzadas en esta cumbre si de hecho
tiene graves implicaciones porque pueda
haber un aumento de los precios en
cualquier caso los países europeos están
preparados se habrá un embargo del
petróleo en dos fases primero ese
importe dejará de importar a finales de
año el petróleo de para que llegue de
mar y luego será por un producto aún en
fechas concretas perdidas se está
preparando esta misma semana se espera
que se preparen estas sanciones en
cualquier caso es muy importante para
rusia 70.000 millones de euros que los
países europeos pagaron el año pasado
prácticamente se van a dejar a pagar a
partir de ahora para rusia
vamos a ucrania el ejército de este país
continúa soportando los ataques rusos en
la ciudad de severodonezk la última gran
urbe en la región del donbass bajo el
control de kiev moscú sin embargo ya
controla un tercio de esa ciudad al
tiempo que el ejército ruso también
concentra su ofensiva en la ciudad sam's
club ians el imán en medio de los
combates en terreno naciones unidas
informó que son más de 4.000 los civiles
que han perdido la vida y casi 5.000 los
que han resultado heridos desde el 24 de
febrero día en que inició la invasión
en la dirección de donges el enemigo
dispara a las unidades de nuestras
tropas con morteros artillería y
múltiples lanzacohetes a lo largo de la
línea de contacto los esfuerzos
principales se centran en establecer el
control sobre la ciudad de severodonezk
el enemigo utiliza activamente la guerra
electrónica se reagrupa y se prepara
para las acciones ofensivas en la
dirección de lehman el enemigo trató de
inspeccionar las rutas de mayor avance
en el área del asentamiento del imán
sufrió pérdidas y se retiró en las áreas
de los asentamientos de cbre ed o'neill
es hitos que se están realizando
operaciones de asalto las hostilidades
continúan
voy a trabajar en información de último
minuto llega que un bombardeo ruso
impacto un tanque de ácido nítrico en la
ciudad ucraniana de severodonezk
estaremos atentos a la ampliación de
esta noticia entre tanto un tribunal
ucraniano condenó a dos soldados rusos a
11 años y medio de prisión por
bombardear edificios residenciales y un
colegio en el asentamiento de cotel va
se trata de la segunda condena por
crímenes de guerra y se produce cuando
la ofensiva rusa cumple 97 días los
sentenciados son alexander bobby quin y
alexander ivánov cuya defensa había
pedido previamente clemencia al señalar
que seguían órdenes y están arrepentidos
huawei y en la haya la corte penal
internacional continúa su investigación
también sobre posibles crímenes de
guerra en ucrania hoy la fiscal general
ucraniana deriva benedict cova aseguró
que quien ha identificado a más de 600
sospechosos de crímenes de guerra rusos
y ha comenzado a procesar a unos 80 de
ellos la funcionaria indicó que la lista
de presuntos responsables incluye a
militares políticos y agentes de
propaganda de rusia
el periodista francés frederick de klerk
de 32 años perdió la vida ayer en medio
de un bombardeo ruso contra la región de
lugansk el camarógrafo cubría el
conflicto para el canal de noticias
bfmtv las autoridades locales informaron
que el vehículo blindado en el que se
transportaba fue impactado por la
metralla de un proyectil ampliamos en el
siguiente informe
frederick de klerk
un periodista de 32 años fue asesinado
el lunes en el este de ucrania el
camarógrafo de la cadena de noticias
francesa bfm tv viajaba en un autobús
blindado cerca de una zona de combate en
la región de severodonezk cuando el
vehículo fue alcanzado por la metralla
de un proyectil la ministra de
exteriores francesa de visita en ucrania
condenó el asesinato
si ha cometido un doble crimen un convoy
de evacuación ha sido blanco de un
ataque y un periodista ha sido asesinado
tanto civiles como un periodista
y
era el segundo viaje de leclerc como
reportero a ucrania estaba en una misión
con dos colegas su editor maxim brand
setter que resultó herido en la pierna y
su enlace ucraniana oksana letal utah
que no resultó herida estaban allí para
cubrir una operación de evacuación para
bfmtv leclercq trabajaba para la cadena
francesa desde hacía seis años su muerte
se produce cuando al menos ocho
periodistas han sido asesinados desde el
comienzo de la invasión rusa según
reporteros sin fronteras la organización
sin ánimo de lucro afirma que es
probable que las tropas rusas ataquen
deliberadamente a los periodistas
aquí estaba un joven periodista que
trabajaba para un canal de televisión
francés y que iba en autobús claramente
identificado como vehículo humanitario
así que es muy probable que haya sido
blanco de las fuerzas rusas
las autoridades francesas no
especificaron quien disparó el proyectil
pero la ministra de asuntos exteriores
de francia pidió una investigación
transparente sobre la muerte de frederic
la clase move
este martes se conmemora el día mundial
sin tabaco y tras décadas de advertir a
los fumadores sobre la toxicidad de los
cigarrillos la organización mundial de
la salud señala ahora que el tabaco
también es nocivo para el planeta
buscando que este argumento convenza a
algunas personas de dejar el hábito
cuántos aspectos negativos puede tener
un solo producto el tabaco provoca
cáncer entre otros problemas de salud
sin embargo la organización mundial de
la salud asegura que los cigarrillos no
solo envenenan las personas sino también
el planeta
the force es una gran causa de
deforestación el 5 por ciento de toda la
deforestación es para plantar trabajos
además de los residuos y cerca de 4
billones y medio de colillas de
cigarrillos terminan en los ríos mares y
los océanos cada año contaminando cada
una 100 litros de agua
la oms se defiende que lo mínimo que
podría hacer la industria tabaquera es
pagar por su contaminación por ejemplo
financiando limpiezas como en francia y
en españa
en francés se ha expandido la conciencia
de la responsabilidad de la industria
productora se cobra a la industria por
las cosas que generan en la industria
paga mucho dinero que puede usarse para
limpiar el medio ambiente y sensibilizar
sobre reciclar los residuos del tabaco
público
en francia está multado a lanzar las
colillas de cigarrillo en el exterior si
este tipo de medidas para controlar los
residuos se aplicarán en varios países
sería un gran avance pero la oms asegura
que no sería suficiente con limitar el
vertido de residuos de tabaco sobre el
medio ambiente porque lo más
contaminante es producir los cigarrillos
en sí por lo que la organización quiere
convencer a los fumadores de todo el
mundo a dejar por completo este mal
hábito
ya son al menos 100 los fallecidos a
causa de las inundaciones y
deslizamientos que golpean el noreste de
brasil los hechos se han producido en el
estado de pernambuco
justamente el lunes el presidente jair
bolsonaro visitó la zona tras asegurar
que puso a disposición todos los medios
disponibles para ayudar a los miles de
afectados nunca cayó tonta nunca antes
había subido tanto en tan poco tiempo
vivo muy cerca de aquí conozco a todos
los que murieron y todo cuando sucedió
ese o yo primer examen en el primer
deslizamiento de tierra caso mucho lodo
y pensamos que no sería una cantidad tan
grande después de eso luego volvió como
un tsunami enseguida cayó fetos y
tsunami vamos a oriente medio porque
israel y emiratos árabes unidos firmaron
un histórico acuerdo comercial en dubai
ese primer acuerdo del libre comercio de
israel con un país árabe y ambos países
esperan que traiga crecimiento después
de dos años de pandemia se prevé que el
comercio bilateral anual pueda llegar a
los 10 mil millones de dólares se veamos
más detalles en el informe el ministro
de asuntos exteriores de israel twittean
árabe mientras el embajador de los
emiratos árabes unidos- publicada en
hebreo saludando a lo que llaman un
acuerdo comercial histórico que traerá
un crecimiento cooperación y sueños más
grandes desde que normalizaron las
relaciones en 2020 el comercio se
impulso ahora se eliminarán los
aranceles sobre el 96% de los bienes lo
que se supone que traerá crecimiento a
ambos países y bajará los precios
'israel exportaría productos
tecnológicos diamantes frutas y verduras
mientras emiratos árabes unidos-
exportaría material de construcción
aluminio acero y joyería
estoy segura que esto no solo abre las
oportunidades para la comunidad
empresarial para nuevas iniciativas y
tecnologías en evolución tanto en israel
como los emiratos también inspira a
otros países para que vean que esto es
posible
el objetivo es un comercio bilateral
anual de 10 mil millones de dólares
mucho más que con egipto el aliado árabe
de israel desde hace mucho tiempo aunque
el verdadero objetivo no es el comercio
bilateral sino utilizar el territorio
emiratí como centro para miles de
empresas israelíes que esperan llegar a
los comercios de la región y de toda
asia la firma se produce en el momento
de mayor tensión entre israel y la
autoridad palestina el domingo
activistas israelíes marcharon por
jerusalén y los emiratos árabes unidos
condenaron lo que denominaron el asalto
al recinto de mezquita de al-aqsa lugar
sagrado para el islam pero también el
más sagrado para el judaísmo los
palestinos habían criticado la
normalización de los lazos con israel
el gobierno emiratí dice que espera que
el diálogo y el comercio traigan paz el
presidente del club de fútbol liverpool
le exigió una disculpa a la ministra de
deportes francesa por el trato que
recibieron los aficionados del equipo en
la final de la champions league del fin
de semana según los medios de
comunicación locales tom werner escribió
que estaba en total incredulidad después
de que el ministerio ministra culpar a
inicialmente al liverpool de ayudar a
causar el caos en el partido en parís el
gobierno francés también asegura que el
fraude masivo de entradas contribuyó al
caos o fuera del estadio francés el
sábado
firme en su argumentación el ministro
interior francés culpó a la venta de
entradas falsas a los hinchas del
liverpool por el caos del sábado en la
final de la champions league sin aportar
pruebas legal damana afirmó que más de
dos tercios de los seguidores del
liverpool tenían entradas fraudulentas
que había entre 30 y 40 mil personas más
afuera del stade francais de las que
puede albergar el estadio que son 80 mil
tanto con entradas como sin ellas con
entradas falsas o sin ninguna estos
problemas sólo ocurrieron con el
liverpool
querida que el martes se supo que el
gobierno francés había sido advertido
sobre las entradas falsas que se
esperaban para el partido una carta
enviada por la policía cuatro días antes
de la final decía que algunos hinchas
intentarían utilizarlas para acceder al
estadio el partido del sábado entre el
liverpool y el real madrid se retrasó
más de media hora
los aficionados del equipo inglés
esperando en largas filas mientras que
algunos incluidos niños recibieron los
gases lacrimógenos lanzados por la
policía el ministerio de deportes
francés ha ordenado una investigación
sobre el incidente que deberá
completarse en un plazo de 10 días por
su parte el organismo rector del fútbol
europeo ha encargado una investigación
independiente la revisión exhaustiva
examinará la toma de decisiones la
responsabilidad y los comportamientos de
todas las entidades implicadas en la
final una vez recibidas las conclusiones
la uefa evaluará los siguientes pasos el
liverpool ha criticado el trato que
recibieron los aficionados por parte de
las fuerzas de seguridad y acusan a las
autoridades francesas de sacar
conclusiones sin una investigación
rigurosa
es todo por el momento en france 24
ustedes les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a visitar nuestra web
france24 puntocom para ampliar toda la
información y repetir este y otros
programas continúen con nosotros que
volvemos en breve
[Música]